alright let's take our last call today 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we will take our last
call from an another than the 3 1 5 area
code caller what's your name and where
are you calling from today hi my name is
Jay and I'm calling from upstate New
York great what's on your mind I was
watching your videos having to do with
Donald Trump's literacy levels and his
ability to orth inability to read hmm I
was wondering what you thought of him
having such a privileged life never
having been challenged coasting through
life how much of that is just an
unwillingness to learn or what the
possibility of him having an actual
learning disability is yeah I think both
of those ideas are relevant here and a
bunch of people emailed me saying David
he graduated from UPenn obviously the
guy can read not to be super clear we
never argued Trump literally cannot read
obviously he can read the question is at
what level can Donald Trump read and
there's no doubt that when you basically
buy your way into an Ivy League school
UPenn is considered I believe right yes
when you buy your way into an Ivy League
school it's not shocking to think you
might be able to get by doing less work
than might be expected of a student that
just barely got in and is on scholarship
and accumulating student loans etc etc
so that number one I think that there's
no doubt that having led such a
privileged life made it so that he never
needed to have the same deep level of
understanding of a number of different
issues now to your second point whether
we might be dealing with a learning
disability many people have emailed me
about that and said you know what may be
going on here is that Donald Trump does
have either a learning disability or
dyslexia some people even suggesting
that it could be other things which I
won't necessarily mention because
they're very even more speculative I
think that there's a lot to that and if
that's the case it's nothing to make fun
of right it's just we should be aware
that the president has a learning
disability if that's the case and that
it may impact his ability to be a fully
present commander-in-chief of the United
States I think anyone else that was
elected president would kind of market
that too they would be like well I have
this disability dyslexia but despite
that despite all the setbacks that I
have I was only able to be elected here
what a great story of this country you
know oh yeah I guess it's hard for me to
imagine a president marketing that I do
believe nepotism has played a role
because for instance he does not have
the weight on him that if he is not
keeping up to a certain grade point
average he will lose a scholarship yeah
however I do think it's kind of
difficult if it's just specular nning
disability yeah and a lot of people
writing in and basically saying without
any specific evidence that he has a
learning disability or dyslexia they
felt that it's much more plausible that
that's why he exhibits the signs of
illiteracy that we pointed to relative
to just oh the guy never learned how to
read which is not not really what we're
suggesting either yeah I've seen a lot
of those same people talking about there
should be a test in place for a
President of the United States just as
there's tests to get into business
school or to medical school but I don't
really how would you make a seemingly
objective test yeah I mean I don't know
exactly what would be on it but I'm not
opposed to the idea that you know a test
to be a parent I think would lend itself
to all sorts of discrimination based on
class and and so many other biases a
test to be President of the United
States doesn't strike me as that insane
favoriting IQ there's only three
qualifications you need to be president
natural-born citizen being a citizen
here for 14 years and being above the
age of 35 yeah and he had all three of
those so anyway I hope that sort of
answers your question I think that
there's more to be explored along both
lines the privilege and the learning
disability line I don't know how much
more we're gonna learn about either
though
okay all right thank you so much concur
really really really appreciate it that
does it for phone calls today we will
take calls again that I promise you